[Applause]
much of this video of january the 6th
has never been seen before
recordings of protesters own radio
channels hey brother we're boots on the
ground here we're moving on the capitol
now i'll give you a boots on the ground
update here and
view
[Applause]
sounds of panic among the police
in the chaos evidence of the
coordination among those responsible for
what's been called
an attack on democracy four of the
officers who were on the front line that
day
were the first witnesses in the
committee investigating that riot
and what was at stake you held the land
that day
i can't overstate what was on the line
our democracy they wanted this committee
to be bipartisan
but the only republicans are
high-profile critics of donald trump
no member of congress should now attempt
to defend
the indefensible obstruct this
investigation
or whitewash what happened that day in
the very building that came under attack
the four officers gave america a graphic
reminder
i was grabbed beaten tased
all while being called a traitor to my
country
i was at risk of being stripped of and
killed with
my own firearm one latched onto my face
and got his thumb in my right eye
attempting to gouge it out
i cried out in pain and managed to shake
him off
for the first time i was more afraid to
work
at the capitol than my entire deployment
to iraq
i do my best to keep politics out of my
job
but in this circumstance i responded
well i voted for joe biden does my vote
not count
that prompted a torrent of racial
epithets
one woman in a pink mega shirt yelled
you hear that guys this voted for joe
biden
all four blamed the former president for
his words that day
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell
you're not gonna have a country anymore
his continuing influence on american
politics
hangs over this hearing more than 500
people have been charged over the events
of that day
six months on the fences have gone from
the capital
the building the mob tried to storm
largely back to normal
but the memories and the scars of
january the 6th
live on greg milam sky news